a predator would probably want to take
me but we're taking you because I'm
smaller because okay if you lose that
term time for the latest installment of
change my mind
where we rationalize our positions on
controversial issues this time we set up
shop at the Dallas women's March that
take on the topic of male privilege
you're benefiting from white male
privilege your three boys have hit the
american protecta of privilege they are
white straight male women are sent off
to college with rape whistles while men
are not women who have to take extra
care walking down a street to be safe
you know it's a sort of invasion of
boundaries of women that men do not
experience what can men do leaving here
be better convinced but what do you
think what defines privilege and are
males particularly white males in twenty
twenty more privileged than anybody else
let me know in the comments section now
I should note we did have a few
disturbances namely violent assaults
from two transgender individuals but you
can see more on that if you click the
video in the box above on to our first
productive conversation with a locked
and loaded
Amaury men of quality support women's
equality alright
your name is Omari that's what's gonna
see your other side your hate does not
make America great that's right I think
we both agree no no hate would make a
country great that's right but that
doesn't mean that anyone who votes for
Donald Trump is hateful does it doesn't
mean okay good alright cuz you know a
lot of these that's why we sit down and
do this to try and cut through the sound
bites and signage so we can actually
have a conversation yeah I appreciate
that thank you I appreciate you sitting
down well so I'm familiar you are was
kind of what we do on at all on I do let
me read your let me brief you with that
but we did have this instance where yes
you you were saying you don't have white
privilege there's a sign saying there's
no such thing I think it's male
privilege right oh sorry I mixed them up
this is white privilege not exist also
well today we're talking about male
privilege but
male priviledge I do actually okay and I
think they're the same you know root
cause okay let's power let's talk about
that so yeah this is kind of what we do
what to change my mind
is about the idea is to not be a bumper
sticker slogan or does something it's
the opportunity to rationalize our
positions on controversial topics okay I
do not waive that male privilege is a
thing are you are you saying that you're
gonna finish my function yeah I don't
believe that male privilege as its
presented particularly from the ilk of
folks who are here today is a thing okay
I don't believe that we live in a rape
culture if you disagree with me you are
more than welcome to change my mind
so seems we can start with male
privilege yeah okay but also are you
saying that this whole set of is to just
prove you're right and improve the other
side wrong and increase of viewership I
don't I don't know you not the goal for
you know the goal is for everyone to see
something that's unedited and not a
cable news bar okay yeah so none of this
will be edited everything that you say
yeah
well 100% air alright I won't interrupt
you or cut you off there more than one
way to change my mind all right and it's
cool try to no Cooper was a no other
gentleman we split I just an utter like
I'm a hello mother hello father
all right so let's do this good
I appreciate the the candor to the
positive setup you got going on so I
know No
okay cool so male privilege yeah well
the fact that you got where you are and
you've got this power you know a woman
could have done it but it would have
been a lot harder for it yeah so male
privilege is this idea that your life is
not being a male doesn't mean you don't
have difficulty or challenge sure it
just means that your gender is not one
of the things making your life more
challenging okay and that is exclusive
to males I mean all kind there's all
kinds of different privileges okay but
in terms of gender so there could be
female privilege as well
no no not really no I don't think so
okay so then how would you I guess sort
of substantiate that substantiate yeah
why what allows you to make the
presupposition that my life inherently
as a male is easier than a female and
that privilege only exists for males see
that's where I have a disconnect all
right I mean I could pull up some stats
but I mean generally we know that women
make less money than men really women
are the victims of rape and sexual
violence at the hands of men much more
often okay
than the other way around right and you
kind of just go down the list of the
ways that women get screwed over in our
society and that I appreciate you I know
you're making a great I want you to
continue making a great case so it was
paid more yeah raped more right women
yeah
and please yeah continue but you know I
mean I haven't looked at the whole list
of just sort of even just is it and it's
it's something as simple as the lived
experience of women right where my wife
who you she would have loved to have
this conversation with you but her job
prevents her from doing that you can't
be on camera but she her experiences she
walks down the street and you know
depending on the men that are there she
she's objectified she's turned into a
sexual object right by a group of men
who are saying oh yeah I want to do this
and that to your body that's a really
valid point so object you know walking
down the street just not feeling safe in
your own skin or feeling like you could
be a full human being whereas joy I
don't have to worry what I wear when I
walk out the house I don't have to worry
if I have a tank top than mine right yo
leave it just showing and that I'm gonna
get unwanted attention
so that's proud of your great eye
because I think maybe where we would
agree is legally there are no recognized
rights that men enjoy in 2019
20 20 20 I know if you do that still
keep laying 2019 yeah there are no
legally recognized rights afforded to
men in 2020 not afforded to women so we
would agree on that you're talking more
so societal sort of ramification and
actually I'm not sure about that you
know women got the right to vote in 1920
so we're a hundred years on from that so
they can vote yeah but what other things
are in there that you know I I'm not
sure that legally there aren't biases
against women still yeah there may be
there may not I don't think what are
okay well another thing if you have some
I would be won't have any but I would be
curious to look and see so maybe for
example you know if you this whole
abortion thing mm-hmm if you have a
child and the child isn't healthy
because you were taking drugs at the
time because you're an addict or
whatever and then you get thrown in jail
for child abuse the woman's getting
thrown in jail the man who impregnated
her is not getting thrown in jail maybe
that's something to look at as far as a
standard that impacts women I'm sorry
still differently than it does men I
don't mean to interrupt you but I don't
know how do you mean that if a mother
abuses her child and goes to jail you
believe the father should go to jail no
I'm saying in terms of pre what do
prenatal drug use okay you know you have
a child born with some right or that's
not healthy because they didn't when
they were doing drugs they were doing
drugs where they just didn't get the
right prenatal care and that's
considered abuse I'm not really sure I
just I'm just saying why sure because we
had this conversation a hundred years
ago and a day and it would be like well
clearly women are legally not right
don't have the same rights as far as
voting yeah for example but what other
examples could there be that we don't
pay attention to or aren't as pivotal as
the right to vote so I want to make sure
that I that I understand to you brought
up the idea of women are raped more
often yeah they do the women are paid
less being able to walk down the street
and I just wanted to see where we find
common ground
sounds to me like today we probably
agree that it's not really a legal issue
as far as rights afforded you're talking
more about societal issues which i think
is a valid point right I think it's just
credit to the artisan issues really it's
like how do we treat our neighbors and
our friends or our people we don't how
do we treat our women yeah I think it's
really important yeah
before we get to those I know you
mentioned women getting the right to
vote how did that happen
my understanding is that there was women
suffragists who went out and Marsha just
like we're doing now so that women could
cast a ballot right and like was that
most women that did that yeah I don't
think most women were out there but I
don't know do you know why listen for
that understand like you were saying
that men obviously were in positions of
powers when you first said yeah back to
when they got the right to vote okay so
how does a woman cast a ballot to get
the right to vote if she can't vote she
has to agitate she has to who gave the
right to vote I guess is my question who
switched the loss that women could vote
well the men in power must have decided
that they should do that
good for them I don't know if I could
Pat them on the back of it should have
been done it should have been like well
someone I'll do it don't deserve a pat
on the back well at all some someone did
not have to say that women were inferior
in the first place to not be able to
vote so that's what those are the men
that started it and those men should
have fixed it before it the game of
problem so we just did as men what we
should have done in the first place
right so I don't know if we're given
these special kudos for we but the menu
that's what I don't know if they get any
special kudos for doing what I think I
think when someone does something right
I you should be praised for it I don't
know about that because yeah yeah
something right you're writing or wrong
yeah I think this would be praised for
doing that I'm not sure all this sounds
real like you're trying to right wrongs
today of social justice No
yeah I am but I don't want to be pat on
the back for doing what I should be
doing I want to I want to lift up the
people that are being oppressed sure and
Pat and when they step up and I'm
supporting them they deserve the credit
for for the change that they forced us
to make on their behalf I agree not that
it's bad that these men I just like I
think people you know I think the fact
that you know Abraham Lincoln signed the
Emancipation Proclamation should have
been a much longer before that yeah but
I think that that's a good thing
yeah that's a good thing like that
yeah good point so even Lincoln I don't
say you know oh what a great man you
know if he didn't exist and he hadn't
done that I could still be in Chains
right now so of course I appreciate it
but I don't know if she was born in
Africa you could still be in change
right now the Middle East the car I
don't know anywhere across the world
this is true yeah terrible point being
don't raise up this man because he used
his privilege for good above the folks
that you know in the doubt that we're
one down and Rosa yeah put them first
let's put the attention where it belongs
people who have fought for their rights
and gotten their rights and pushed the
more progressive among the oppressors
yeah what if let's say Abraham Lincoln
signed the Emancipation Proclamation
right let's say Abraham Lincoln outlawed
slavery and let's say slaves themselves
didn't want to be free this is not the
case well I'm saying the women's
suffrage movement okay wouldn't that
person wouldn't those people deserve to
be praised if for example the
overwhelming majority of women didn't
want the right to vote they were the
ones advocating against it not men so
wouldn't the men deserve the praise if
they gave him the right to vote when
women didn't want it I'm totally
confused by this question a majority of
women didn't want the right to vote
oh wow do you know that no yeah the
reason why was because they thought that
it would actually increase their work
burden and increase their quality of
life and a lot of people don't know this
but when you had to vote you know it was
actually a privilege in the sense that
you had to either be a landowner
eligible for the draft but I would
forget forgetting though that's where
it's mandatory firefighting service
right and so women didn't want the right
to vote
which is kind of interesting people
assume they did why men wanted one why
do you people fight so hard against
these groups getting their rights to
vote if it's such a burden when the
point is they didn't it was there wasn't
a push to vote and then when it came to
a vote
most women didn't want it it was the men
who passed it so would that change
assuming I'm not lying yeah would that
change your opinion at all if men even
in the face of a majority of women not
wanting the right to vote said you know
what it's the right thing to do you
should still have the right to vote they
deserve any praise no I don't think so
okay I think so when I do take your
points I think your voice is really good
because I need to learn up get up learn
about history because I think that's
very powerful that you're aware of these
things and you can pull out these
factoids that it's a factoid that the
black widows venom is 15 times more
potent another diamondback rattlesnake
right in fact the majority of women
didn't want the right to vote is kind of
you know we've been lied to at large
ya know for sure that said I appreciate
and I didn't mean to disparage your
factoy
no white male I can take it you can call
me a piece of for all I care I guess I
understand it that you made let's go
back to women paid more oh okay well
then let me rattle off really quick
women aren't paid more for the same work
women are actually not sexually abused
or domestically abused more and as far
as the anecdotal know as far as the
anecdotal idea that women can walk alone
home at night well it wouldn't
necessarily be the same for 115 pounds
rim pee man and 180 pound female MMA
fighter so you guys had a go to we can't
really look at that statistically but no
actually men are raped more often when
you
include the prison population and that
does matter because men are convicted
much more harshly for the exact same
crimes as women as far as the 77 cents
on the dollar if you believe that I
think you really should do a little bit
more research because all that does is
compare the median income from women in
the workforce to the median income of
men in the workforce it doesn't take
into account hours worked it doesn't
take it into account risk of labor
doesn't take into account travel time
away from family when you account for
all of those facets women actually in
most studies make a little bit more than
men but exactly the same so I think it's
important that if we're gonna have this
conversation and that's why I want you
sit down and speak and I know some
people came in hot I think it does
matter to speak the truth I agree with
that you could drop the mic Crowder you
just killed it we said you were tired so
white man Stephen such an uninteresting
name something like Oh Mari I'll never
forget your names but I always forget
but Stephen your resume is gonna get
more looks and more callbacks than mine
because your name is regular you know I
like to see the stats on that you could
look up I was my name was also
associated with the first martyr so my
parents weren't necessarily destiny for
greatness with that one it's named our
son after him yeah I'm not thrilled
about it yeah but I guess no you
definitely dropped a lot of points there
that I don't have a response for but I
just say as a man in my heart I know
that women out there are struggling
under oppression all over this country
and the facts are the facts but people
can choose different facts and I and I
just know what I don't think I can do
different fact I think your first
statement was correct facts are the
facts and I think that yes there is
there are examples of male privilege for
sure but there are also examples of
female privilege yeah and so I think
it's Porton to recognize that there are
privileges that go both ways there is
white privilege in the sense that
there's certain advantages at white
people would have but there's also black
privilege that advantages that black
people would have there's male privilege
and that's certainly there's some
biological managers and males enjoy
there's female privilege and that
a lot of these females enjoy but you
don't believe that advantage doesn't
mean the same as privilege privilege is
like an overarching pattern of
preference and power in the society and
that's what you got but that's what I
got him a white male I know you want to
go but I appreciate our line thank you
thank you very much I appreciate keeping
it civil okay be well stay safe okay
thank you and worry thank you very much
ma'am well that went well
remember if you want these videos to
continue please do consider joining Mudd
Club at lot of credit calm flushed mug
Club $69 annually for students that's
active military you get this wonderful
hand etched mug and a full daily show
not available on YouTube along with
about the place to be the entire catalog
it is the only thing that allows these
videos to continue if not that's fine
enjoy the rest of the show bookmark this
channel and check back for new videos
every weekday at 9 p.m. Eastern let's
get back to it meet Hannah mail
privileges is a myth it's not a real
thing as it's been presented here today
if you disagree you're more than welcome
to change my mind male privilege as in
that men have more advantages than women
do ok I mean of course I mean sexism
exists every like tier of our society in
every way in terms of employment women
still get paid the same position for the
same work just because I just want to
make sure we don't as a cyst white male
and we've had some people who were upset
can you define woman
um I think gender is more fluent than
people who are more traditionalist like
to think I am very for trans rights and
loving trans people and wanting them to
live their fullest lives like safely I
define gender as what you do what you
identify with how do we define woman I
want to make sure that I understand who
identifies as female okay I mean there's
I mean it's a complicated world I can
see how people who maybe for more
traditional societies like my parents my
parents are from Ethiopia even though
they're progressive like politically and
socially it's certain things are kind of
difficult to wrap your mind around and
that doesn't make you a bigot
necessarily sure but I
I'm very forward transition with you are
talking about sexism or systemic
advantages toward men not afforded to
women you were also including trans men
to women trans women have their own
issues I mean trans people are beaten up
attacked killed in the streets simply
for being who they are I mean I am
terrified for them to be honest
particularly in communities that may not
be as educated may not have some as much
exposure to people like them okay I just
wanted to make sure that I didn't yeah
overstep my bounds so we're including
trans male to females among women okay
so continue as you you were presenting
the idea of systemic male privilege I I
think the whole idea that women have
their role in the home and
that they don't belong in the workforce
they don't belong in things in positions
of leadership I think that has been
dismantled to a large extent sure but
there is very much still the idea of you
know a good thing of what the idea that
women shouldn't necessarily be in the
home I think the wave of feminism that I
see and I understand that most young
people around my age accept is that
women can do whatever they want to do
and that's what I believe if a woman
wants to be a stay-at-home mom great if
a woman wants to be a career woman never
get married
phenomenal I think women should do what
makes them happy people should just do
what makes my dad agree with all that
she wants to be a career woman or not
getting a phenomenal I think it's her
choice I don't think it's a good one and
statistics would bear that out but I
agree I think feminism if I'm not
mistaken if we both agree is women
making the choice I think people in
general if you're not breaking any laws
or hurting anyone you should do whatever
you want should be allowed to do what
you want as long as you know under those
parameters I think going back to the
idea of like basic feminism is male
privilege so I guess I bet we did talk
about one more thing when we talk about
the two genders and their relationship
we need to talk about race and feminism
a lot of the times black women feel
disheartened by mainstream feminism or
what they call white feminism because
the statistic they bring this statistic
about women make this number cents to
every dollar as well in Native American
women we always forget Native Americans
sorry no that's not just on you I think
as a culture we do but we have to always
always always be cognizant of
intersectionality when it comes to
relationships between the genders so a
lot to keep track of so uh let me guess
trying to laser in on some points that
we can find out where we agree or
disagree you talk about systemic
discrimination and male privilege that's
kind of what obvious is a catalyst for
this conversation can you point to any
single right in 2020 afforded to a man
not afforded to a woman before we get to
societal because I would agree with you
but legally speaking I think as of today
this day and age
but what you have to understand is that
a lot of things on paper are set up a
certain way for equality but in practice
it's very different it's kind of like in
theory there's equality but in practice
there's so many discrepancies but glass
ceiling still exists theory we have
equality what do you mean by that as far
as it is we have the law but there's so
many the law completely but that in
practice yes saying we're not okay and
there were certain things that are
different like for example men can be
drafted women will be into the military
it's female privilege yeah I guess you
could put it that way it depends on
perspective women are not a little how
does it depend on perspective women have
tonight some people want to be in the
military and that's you know maybe we
didn't have a choice men don't it's
complex for example in in Iraq the women
are not allowed in the front lines of
combat sure despite having all the
training being decorated officials in
the army they are not allowed to and
also have some not allowed to talk back
in the Army in Iraq saying there aren't
equal rights in Iraq for women and men
we would both agree on that I'm telling
my wife sensitization the United States
but it's asking me no no no no I'm
talking about in the Iraq war women in
the United States military yeah okay cuz
they can now yeah and let me let's talk
about you see that a systemic
discrimination not allowing women in
different lines I mean if they are just
as skilled in combat if they've
completed their training in their
decorated all they're far less skilled
we had to lower the PT requirements for
women to make it in women couldn't meet
the same requirements that mended so we
lowered them from well in combat it's
not like it's with guns it's with
military-grade weapons so it doesn't
require the same amount we lowered we
lowered the ruk times as far as how long
you run with a pack on your back or
carrying someone who's also in your
platoon we lowered the pull-ups we
lowered the push-ups we lowered
everything for female standards and then
I mean that's female privilege right men
had to meet a certain set of standards
and when women couldn't meet them we
lowered them so I just think that's not
female privilege okay
that's that's promoting equality among
the genders how's that promoting
equality though by lowering allowing
them to be involved directly in serving
our country giving women all the same
opportunities it's like I think you're
moving into the territory of affirmative
action that's what I said here no what
we were talking about was the draft and
I think that's important yeah because
you said that's not a privilege for a
woman to not be automatically eligible
for the draft where we both agreed that
feminism should be a choice right that's
the idea a woman choosing her life a
woman has the privilege of choosing not
to go in the military a man doesn't and
this is kind of important because it
ties to the idea you know of women's
right to vote we do realize that men
only have the right to vote because they
were eligible for the draft and
bucket-brigade and owned property and
women got the right to vote without
being eligible for the draft
um I believe that women had wait what
say it again okay so are you so do you
know when women's suffrage when women
were given the right to vote you know 18
20 not for women of color women of color
didn't the right to vote yes but 1919
ratified in 1920 yes black women were
before in the women's suffrage movement
there was a lot of racism there are most
often let's stay with this the rate or
time of male and female so who gave
women the right to vote who voted for
women have the right to vote progressive
men sure okay did most women had to
fight for 80 years they didn't right
most women didn't want the right to vote
did you know that the majority of them
didn't you know why because of the draft
because of bucket-brigade because voting
was not seen as just an inherent
birthright no matter what it came with
certain sets of responsibilities to
allow women to vote who didn't want it
those responsibilities when you are
taught black is blue your entire life
you will believe black is blue that
women did not belong in because of their
voting they may vote for women into
office and they did not believe that
women belonged in positions of power and
positions of leadership they were
brainwashed that's being indoctrinated
okay so the men who were brainwashing
them to not be able to vote we're the
ones who overwhelmingly supported and
got them the right to vote even though
women whelmingly
supported the right to vote for women's
far as people the people who are
oppressing women for centuries who are
forcing them in arranged marriages were
there raped and being forced to bear
children that they they didn't want that
they couldn't provide for who women were
oppressed since the beginning of time
except for maybe a few classical Greek
societies women were oppressed in every
corner of the world women the majority
of the men did not support the right to
vote the majority of men were trying to
disenfranchise women suffrage movement
since it begun and in 1840 I'm a little
confused
how do laws we're the ones who put susan
b anthony in jail for trying to register
to vote
how do laws get passed through both
houses of Congress okay
and in order for it to pass I just want
to make assume I don't know a whole lot
does it require a majority to vote it in
yes okay and was that majority back then
would it have comprised of men
[Music]
men when they were facing the pressure
of a cultural shift they did what was
right okay they had changes of hearts
they had they changed their perspective
and that was because of the tireless
work of these men tried to
disenfranchise them every step of the
way that's not accurate
but let's move on to today to 2020 maybe
we'll just disagree I do have some
sources hereafter which will be
interesting some kind of data on how
many women wanted the right to vote
again provided that it came with the
current set of responsibilities that
voting it at the time but we go back to
today we both reckon we both agree there
are no legally recognized rights for it
to men not to women well you mentioned
systemic privilege or or societal
privilege could you meet some examples
of that so in 2020 what is male
privilege male privilege is not having
to walk down the street and being afraid
of being sexually harassed of being
catcalled of being objectified being
treated as an object of sex and not a
person with thoughts and feelings and
dreams and goals and complexities you
don't have to walk down the street and
feel afraid the way women do in certain
parts of the country some of us do and
some of us much more so than women and
do you want to talk about other
societies in the world because I would
totally agree with you with societies
like you mentioned I think you mentioned
Ethiopia or in the air Islamic countries
I would agree with you let's talk about
this Christian country but short not
even say the other was an Islamic
country but I know Ethiopia not
necessarily the same kind of rights that
we have in the United States and as a
general across the entire Islamic world
women are not afforded the same rights
as men I think that's horrible
so
the record I obviously think women
should have the right to vote but where
we disagree is I do think it's a female
privilege to not be forced into the
draft now I do take your point here
where you talk about walking down the
street I mean I was just we just had
someone assault us right here to try and
steal the sign it was actually one so it
does happen with men as well now as far
as sexual so I would agree I hate the
sexual objectification of women that's
why I have a problem with feminism
because as I'm sure you know women's
liberation the porn affectation of
culture it's been supported by well I've
even seen women here supporting sex
workers so I think you and I would find
common ground there I think as far as
like so as far as sex work it's not
something that I would want for myself
or my family but I think if it's two
consenting adults I don't see the point
of criminalizing I don't know if we
should completely legalize it right now
but at least decriminalizing it it may
not be a fabulous life choice but an
adult has a right to and oftentimes it's
the conditions of people's lives and so
people understand it's just we were
talking about sexual objectification I
think we agree on that
yeah I don't agree with you on the idea
of walking home and not being fearful
first off I think every woman should
have their head in a swivel and I think
every man should and yeah I do think
that men commit a significant amount a
majority of the violent crime in this
country but it's also perpetrated
against men in other words if we're both
walking down the street at night I am
more likely to be violent I'm talking
more about like sexual assaults
abductions things like that
I a predator would probably want to take
me but we're taking you because I'm
smaller because okay if you lose that
term Oh what term would you use I mean
you know anyway that's beside the point
I physically physically I'm stronger and
you're physically weaker that's what I'm
saying in other words for the same
reason that I would try and help you if
someone were physically assaulting you
because I'm
oh yeah drag me into a van a lot easier
than they could drag you into a van yeah
be hard to drag my fat ass into a van
that being said men are the victims of
violent crimes more than women
what about slut-shaming what about
promiscuity and how women are demonized
for having sexuality because we live in
a very sexy negative society in general
but I thought you just said women were
objectified and seen as sex objects too
often but now you're saying we're
demonizing women if we see them sexually
no you know what I mean I really don't I
think whenever like for example if you
were to have X amount of partners
sexually like if I were to have if I
slept with 12 people and one of my male
cousins left with 12 people who would be
called a [ __ ] I would call you both
maybe you would I'm saying society in
general slut-shamed women a lot more and
I will admit it's women who [ __ ] shame
women a lot yeah women actually as a
matter of fact this is kind of
interesting where you talked about the
objectification of women did you
actually know that women when they've
conducted these studies and I have these
sources for you they did a more recent
one very specific with online dating but
in general women grade men far more
harshly on physical traits than men
grade women men grade women on a bell
curve and actually a far more forgetting
women are far harsher and their
expectations of men physically false
that is on its face absolutely
unequivocally a lie I'm correct women
are judged based on their looks way more
I mean do she young guys see women walk
fine bill oh she's a nine oh she's a
seven oh that person's out of my league
first of all no human being is superior
to any other human being I mean
I really do facets I really resent the
notion that like oh that person is out
of my league I can't pursue them but
women are going back to the ten scale
women are judged on the one to ten scale
a lot more than men are I don't walk by
and go through that's that guy is a
seven oh I should he's not out of my
league let me go talk to him that's not
how women approached her would you women
or judge based on their looks a lot more
women are called ugly women are called
okay can I give you an example
specifically what I'm talking about this
is from the 90s this is from the OJ
trial every day
the press would criticize Marcia Clark's
she is no fashion she has ugly hair she
looks frazzled with her horrible curly
hair and they never go Oh Oh Jay what an
ugly tie he was wearing Oh Johnnie
Cochran oh you know he got his suit at
Goodwill like no one would say that
actually I think of everyone involved
with the OJ trial the one most
remembered for crazy suits was Johnnie
Cochran he was not criticized every
single day and attacked for her looks
the way Marcia Clark was attacked people
were calling her unattractive people
were saying she had no sense of style
like I said about her hair they were not
getting that people would be like oh wow
that suit is kind of out there this is
an example of male privilege to you yes
because they wouldn't be like oh he's
ugly he's unappealing because of his
looks and also can I because I've been
called ugly so many times and rightfully
so not rightfully so so it's teach you
that your looks
personal you're not ugly by any means
are you thank you and by the way my wife
there is out of my league and so would
you be if I were a single male I have no
problem saying no she's not because no
human being is better than anybody else
they are certain facets I'm sure sorry
more physically attractive and I hear
she was beautiful but she's not better
than you because she's beautiful she's
more beautiful than I am
but she did I don't know if that's true
but more people want to have sex with
her than me
can I bring up another point it's a
little bit unrelated but it's related to
Marshall Clark from the OJ trial I call
powerful women [ __ ] they're like oh
she's bossy oh she's a [ __ ] whenever
she has strong views but if a man were
to conduct himself in the same way and
give off the same demeanor they'd be
like oh wow what a strong powerful man
he's really getting it done he's really
sticking it to them but women are taught
oh she's bossy she's a [ __ ] she needs
to stay in her place she needs to order
it for example when women have a serious
face oh we should smile more honey yes
smile more I mean I think everyone
should yes can i express tonight because
we've gotten completely off the
statistical so let me say this is just
ends up being personal so let's have a
personal conversation maybe because I
just had this discussion not that long
ago with a female relative okay
a man is physically attracted to warmth
and tenderness and a woman right that is
an attractive trait because we like nice
women you just talked about [ __ ] she
right so the ideal they call women when
they're powerful knows what they call me
when they're acting like [ __ ] but yes
no all the time because she was a
powerful woman people call Hillary I
like to be able to finish okay I'm sorry
I don't want to be accused of male
privilege but you are speaking very long
I do want to make my point okay okay so
men are physically attracted to
tenderness and warmth from a woman yes a
smiling woman is biologically more
attractive to a man than a frowning
woman now let me tell you why because
men live particularly to please their
wives and women hold on let me finish
and so to us it is attractive to see our
wife or to see the woman that we love
smiling a man and I'm sure if you've
been a relation for any period of time
right how often you get to are you okay
sweetie are you happy okay well this
happens a lot it's often a point of
conflict my wife and I were when did I
juice are you okay are you happy a man
saying hey it's attractive for a woman
to smile more is the equivalent to a
woman saying it's attractive for a man
to listen more
okay can I I'm gonna respond to that the
whole notion of like telling women to
smile transcends relationships it's even
down the street men come up to women go
oh hey honey hey sweetheart smile more
smile and it's very like condescending
think it's very patronizing it's very
much if a stranger came up and said hey
you sure the baby smiled more I'd be
like yeah okay that's kind of crappy but
that's I wouldn't be offended but I
understand it's symptomatic of the
culture of patronizing women of treating
women differently than you would treat
men in that way you shouldn't and that
if that makes sense but you just
supported lowering the PT requirements
in the military so women could join up
because they're weaker is that
patronizing or is that equality because
I'm confused that's equality okay so
saying women you can't do as many
pushups or pull-ups or you can't do them
the the 16 mile run I don't know what
the PT requirements are now may be
different you can't do it as well as men
so we're going to lower it so you can
join the military
that's equality can I say something to
mr. Morris again to for example if you
look at there's not just one general of
the military just how expansive the
military is there several right
do you see even one and a general is not
doing they're older men they're not
doing physical like physically like
strenuous workouts it's mostly
administrative and they don't let women
to even like the desk jobs yeah if that
makes it correct do you or do you have
any military in your family no okay well
I grew up in a military family that's
not correct at all it's not a generals
job is not at all administrative I
frankly I would say that's a bit of
female privilege because you're kind of
live on that topic
it's an incredibly intellectually
strenuous and emotional military science
I'm sure is complex I'm sure they're
very intelligent what I'm saying is
that's not a physical job as much as the
guys in the lower you can't tell me it's
just as physical as the guy who are you
know on the ground men are more suited
to it and that's why they tend to be
general why do why are men more suited
to it well there are two reasons you
just said that there are older men
yes I don't know it takes to become a
general decades probably yes exactly so
that would go back to men being in the
military longer than women certainly in
those positions and yeah if there's like
if there are military like for example
the McCain's are like military royalty
I'm sure it'd be much easier for them to
get that than like above up the street
that may be so I think but I do
appreciate I think we have some other
people who might want to sit down oh
okay thank you very much I appreciate it
thank you thank you keep your head in
the swivel and stay safe too there are
some there's some riffraff around here
[Music]
waiting had been a long time so that's
paluma David Gore whether it is perfect
cigar whether it's beautiful outside
all right so apparently had some some
insights you wanted to sit down and talk
I don't know how familiar you are with
what the segment is to change my mind
that we do it's basically ideas not a
cable news edited sort of talking point
gotcha mash okay leg is a completely
unedited where we can rationalize our
positions on controversial topics
obviously you've seen today the women's
March a lot of people talking about rape
culture male privilege so male
privileges they've described it not a
thing in my opinion and if you disagree
you're more than welcome to change my
mind okay yeah I would say I disagree in
the sense that I do think male privilege
is real in the sense biologically
speaking men are born inherently
stronger they have higher testosterone
levels so they're able to protect
themselves physically a lot more than a
woman who might be untrained in a
martial art or something yeah and in
that sense they have an inherent
strength advantage when it comes to
protecting themselves such as walking
around the streets late at night yeah
and in that sense they do have a certain
privilege yeah I would say that's an
advantage of biological advantage right
right but men are physically stronger
women are physically weaker sure
I would necessarily disagree with that
but that's not really what they're
talking about here as a matter of fact
some women have said the opposite really
said you know I don't need your
protection I don't need your help I can
take care of myself
basically you can even listen to some of
the speakers here so I think some of
them would disagree with you but I don't
disagree with you at all I think that
maybe we would both agree there are no
legal right and we're talking about
privilege which I'm not systemic
discrimination there are no legal rights
afforded to men not afforded to women in
2020 I don't disagree with you entirely
on that point where we disagree that
being said I didn't hear any of the
speaker's today saying that they don't
need men's help they don't need men
support in fact I didn't help I thought
about men's physically protected okay
yeah and I really think women are very
weak and very vulnerable being attacked
by men I don't you know I don't agree
with that but if you if you look so most
of the blue I'm confused okay well what
I'm saying is that if you look at most
of the violent actions
you know they are caused by men than
they are perpetrated by men well I guess
which violent actions we'll be talking
about you know physical harm rape things
of this nature okay so they are the ones
who commit those crimes moral men are
yeah then women then woman yeah that's
probably two men by their very nature
are more aggressive but men are also
disproportionately the victims of these
crimes worst of the moment by other men
yes often unless you're talking about
domestic abuse where the rates are
actually pretty similar men to women
women to men but right as you said women
are weaker so it's not as treated as big
of a deal they have different advantages
I wouldn't like to use a word such as
weaker you know but obviously we're
talking about biological strength then
yes some men have the advantage but that
would mean women are weaker I don't I
mean that's like a trigger word that you
can use because to say women are weaker
I mean that's I I don't think there's a
lot of different types of strength and
women are physically weaker than men
yeah sure sure sure but you know it's
important to delineate that from all of
the other types of strength that there
are sure that way
might have and women do have more than
men right like for example like what
like a emotional strength like
intellectual strength things of this
nature
do you think women are smarter than men
I think well yeah I don't think there is
any difference biologically speaking
between a woman's intelligence and a
man's intelligence we said you said
intellectual strength is not an
advantage for the serious thing it's
equal now that women are smarter you
know
most humans are very similar in that
aspect and there's another difference
between any certain race or gender in
terms of intellectual capacity yeah I
think that's pretty I would agree with
that
okay but you listed those as advantages
you said for example you didn't want to
use the word weaker in relation to
physical strength you said that was a
trigger word but then he said women have
some advantages over men and then you
listed emotional strength and
intellectual strength so I'm confused it
sounded like you were saying that
they're emotionally stronger than minor
like it could be I think that could be
emotionally stronger than men okay you
know and men are physically stronger
than women they're weaker physically
that being said movements like this are
extremely important because it's
important for us as men to show
solidarity with our women and with all
sorting people who are sharing this
experience that we have you know we're
all trying to get the same exact thing
which is just a better life for
ourselves for our family for our
community so I think it's very important
to show our unity and our solidarity
with with people that we maybe we don't
even agree with yeah well I do show
solidarity but I show solidarity with
women who share my values not because of
their gender most of these women here
wouldn't represent the values not only
myself but of half of the women in
America okay yeah I guess what are the
values here that you're showing by
saying that you know male privilege is a
myth that men are in all terms stronger
than women why don't women are weaker
you said that okay well I heard they're
physically stronger than women I said so
women are physically weaker than men
that's what I heard you say that's
correct
yeah I was bring with you okay no I yeah
word weaker yes you can say men are
stronger than women physically but you
think it's an appropriate say women are
weaker than men yeah because we're not
putting it in the proper context okay
what would be the proper kind of
strength strength bridge yeah going in
that sense and I think you agreed with
me on this that men do have that male
privilege when it comes to having that
strength that physical strength sure of
being able to going around and have more
more confidence that they won't be raped
or taken advantage of or oh no that's
not you salted
men are raped far more often if you look
at other countries around the world
there are several instances where women
are raped and the accusers end up going
off scot-free I agree yes like in
Islamic countries
you know this just happened in India and
not too long ago yeah you know and then
the accuser or the the victim was on her
way to court and there was another
tragic attack where they actually set
her on fire I know so it's very
important for these movements where we
show solidarity that it's not just an
American it's not just for people in the
United States we need to show our values
which I hope you would support as
American that women can be show our
solidarity with not only other men but
other women who and everybody all around
the world in order to support the values
which maybe you and I have in common
which I'm not sure what your values are
yeah well no I certainly would would
value that I don't think that women
should be burned alive for accusing men
of rape or being raped or [ __ ] would you
agree that they should not be raped
of course okay yeah then thank God we
don't live in a rape culture in the
United States where rapists are
prosecuted and convicted now I don't see
a lot of these marches going on in India
I would like to and I haven't seen any
signs of people talking about liberating
women in India or Islamic countries
would that be something you'd like to
see more of I would like to see you
fight the the propose the argument that
male privilege
in other countries that are not the
United States what do you mean I think
male priviledge might is not a myth in
places like Islamic countries or Saudi
Arabia where women didn't have the right
to drive by themselves until recently
that's true I don't but in the United
States there are no rights afforded to
men that aren't afforded to to women now
that being said I agree with you that
men you know women are physically weaker
than men men are stronger than women I
don't necessarily consider that a
systemic privilege I consider that a
biological advantage and I would agree
with you not on intellect not
unnecessarily emotional capacity but on
the flip side of that coin we probably
agree women enjoy some biological
advantages or privileges that men don't
so you're saying that we are both
privileged that men and women are
privileged yes in different ways okay
all right I agree with you you agree
with me on that no I think we just
reached an agreement oh yeah I said we
agree on a lot what I do what I do
disagree with is obviously the
perpetuation of this idea that there's a
patriarchal society or male privilege or
a rape culture or that if we want to
support women we have to support these
women so see I support the women who
showed up for pro-life women women who
maybe support the values that I support
and they're women too and that makes up
you know 50 percent of the country so I
think it's a misrepresentation of the
women of America to take this march
wholesale as emblematic of all women's
points of view let's see I would
disagree with that I think that this
March is actually purely case in point
pro-woman
well no they're not a lot of abortion
signs Pro green New Deal signs I mean
this is Pro leftist Democratic policy
nevertheless it is it should be a
woman's right to choose what is able to
what they're able to do with their own
body I mean it should not be up to men
you know in government to decide what we
can do what we can have our own bodily
autonomy sure I hope that you would
agree with
so let me clarify abortion was not one
of the topics of discussion on that day
but since this gentleman brought up a
woman's right to choose I thought it
warranted a bit more exploration I would
agree that no one has the right to tell
somebody else what they can do with
their own body provided they're not
hurting someone yeah oh great yeah the
baby in the womb is not their body I
guess we disagree on that why so let me
ask you this you believe that the baby
in a woman's womb is you believe that's
her body not a different body I believe
yeah they're inherently connected so how
many fingers of the woman now that's
that's beside the point
no it is the exact point no how many
feet does she have does a woman have a
penis if it's a boy yeah see I
completely disagree with the whole
premise of this notion because you're
saying that the baby inside of the mom
is separate and disconnected you're
saying it's the same so how many are
women adapted I'm saying they're
connected it's the same body I want to
make sure I understand you said the
woman has the right to do whatever she
wants with that baby and by the way I
understand that women like to people
like to go to this argument if I
disagree with them because if I have a
penis I can't have an opinion but you're
surrounded by a lot of women who
disagree with your point right actually
how many fingers and toes does that
woman have if it's her body does she
have 20 fingers and toes
ah either way I still support women
whether they are pro-life which I don't
agree with whether they are pro-choice I
support them plain point-blank how do
you have these is for all women because
I am NOT someone that says if you don't
believe in my values if you don't
believe in what I stand for you don't
have any rights you don't have a right
to speak no this is America no no in
America you have rights
sure and you should be able to speak
your mind as you are you should be able
to basically say whether you are
pro-life whether you're pro-choice great
I want you to be heard sure and that's
what this March is about what a show I
hear they will forgive me for a second
but you were the one who said I should
have no
say and what a woman does with her own
body correct so you said I have no right
to an opinion and then I said but myself
along with many women here
and all by a lot biologists would tell
you that that is not her body the baby
in the womb so the only person here
arguing that someone has no right to an
opinion is you but I don't because I
have a penis what's your name Steven
Steven I should not have a right to tell
you that you should not be able to smoke
that cigar I should not have a right to
tell you that you should not be able to
drink alcohol or do whatever it is you
want to degree as long as you are not
hurting somebody else I agree that's
what that's why I'm coming from I agree
with you now I may have a different
opinion I may have an opinion that says
I don't think you should do short
crystal meth but whether you want to do
that or not whatever in your body if
you've never tried meth what a trip
I'll take your word okay all right well
take my word for no but I'm still saying
it's not an accurate comparison because
we're talking about another body you
have yet to explain to me let me ask you
this when does this become another body
here's a fetal development shirt I
wasn't even planning on talking about
abortion today okay yeah you know
honestly me neither and I'm sure you
already have talking points so you say
it's the woman's body where in this
chart does it become a separate body
once I cut the umbilical cord not saying
that you know abortion should be up
until that point why not well that's
just not my values okay well why not if
it's not a person if it's not another
body
what's why shouldn't you be able to
abort up until the head crowns but I
don't think it's the right thing to do
yeah why I don't understand why if it's
if it's just it's like flipping a Tony
why do you think that you know there
should
not be any abortion why do you think
that this is not part of a woman's body
yeah because the only way to accurately
and consistently delineate what
constitutes a person would be a
conception what about an ideological
yeah so let's go I would even say this
she realizes that that's you as that
little zygote do you realize your hair
color your facial hair your bone
structure whether you were in any or an
Audi whether you would grow chest hair
your intellect your genetic code that is
entirely unique to you separate from the
mother and the father is created at the
moment of conception it's the only way
to accurately and consistently delineate
now if you don't believe that that's the
case that the idea of a new unique body
shouldn't be the standard-bearer then
you need to have a pretty clear litmus
test and it sounds to me like you just
said well I don't think up until the
umbilical cord is cut but I still think
it's wrong for abortion to happen that
late in the pregnancy but I understand
what correct correct you are you're
misrepresenting what I said okay
I don't want it something else I was
basically saying that the the baby is
connected to the mother quite literally
until that time
okay because you asked me when a when do
they stop being connected so if it's no
I asked you if it was a woman's body and
you said it was I believe that women
look whether it is a separate life you
know or whether it is you know able to
be independent on its own which I don't
think you know even up until any of
these stages no of course you know you
live it on the balcony you know in the
winter wood dies okay this is something
that we you know more people that can
disagree that have differing opinions
and different points of view should come
to to an agreement through discussion
through disagreement sure drinking our
own valid points of view just as yours
is is equally as valid as mine however I
would have to defer this to you know
scientists or people who are more
educated on this matter not saying that
your opinion is is therefore null
to ground me I do value your opinion
yeah well my opinion comes from a
science textbooks okay okay that's what
defines life it begins at conception
scientifically we can change and I'm
saying if you would like to change that
you can but your barometer which is as
long as it's attached if I'm not
mistaken my what I'm saying is a women
now in my point of view I think you know
generally first trimester is safe even
going up to you know some parts of the
second trimester okay I get a little bit
of hesitation when they gets anywhere
past that but then again why I just
don't think it's its proper you know I
think that by then you know with too
much of a is formed where it now it is
more of a viable baby more more reliable
human being okay so you're against
abortion in the third trimester you
believe that shouldn't that shouldn't be
allowed I think that abortions should be
able to be provided because if you don't
give people the option to do it cleanly
safely then they're gonna do on their
own and in the third trimester but you
just said that people taking that into
their own hands and then you're gonna
have a loss of life you murder according
your own definition you said in the
third trimester I'm sorry I'm talking
about
you know one where you don't have any
medical overseeing where you don't have
any doctors that are part of it and it's
still being it can be no life no story
master issues there you know by by not
having these women in a healthy sterile
safe environment so you're against
abortions in the third trimester except
in a healthy safe no no no no no once
again mister representing what I'm gonna
try to understand your point I I am Pro
women's choice for them to do what they
want with their body until when
point-blank period what they want to do
with their body so just like rust no no
no no no okay so that's like the same
exact way until what I am for you
smoking your cigars doing whatever
you want with your body I am for women
to have that choice to have that
education to have that availability and
their security of being with a doctor
all the way up until the umbilical cord
is cut no okay so we're not gonna till
when I'm not the arbiter to say in my
point of view I would say somewhere up
until you know in the generally in the
second trimester okay but of course
every killer changes from the second
trimester to the third trimester that
makes it unacceptable in your opinion
obviously we know that there's more
development happening but I think it's
very important to look and see what
where is the phase of development
because as we know different organisms
different babies develop at faster rates
and others okay so forget it was your
name again
David David so David if David you're you
can wave your wand right now I'm just
trying to understand your position on
abortion you can determine abortion law
it is legal up until whether you or I
agree with it or disagree with it can we
agree that abortion if it's going to
happen which we know people are going to
abort their babies anyway at a certain
point
shouldn't it be safe shouldn't it be in
an environment where they won't
potentially die because you know I'm
always dying I'm talking about the
mother I'm talking about the baby and so
I'm asking you you are president you can
you're a dictator abortion is legal
up until another dictator another
dictator in that world and I would not
do it without the advisors without my
advisors both you know doctor advisors
scientific advisors and I wouldn't want
to hear what the people have to say okay
yeah I'm not a dictator I'm not saying
you're dictator I'm saying in a perfect
world I'm trying to understand where you
draw the line but you're not in a
perfect world we don't have abortion in
today's world where do you draw the line
final girl my life final dough I say
today we need to have safe and available
abortions for women
require it who need it who aren't as
advantaged and as privileged zero and
who have more capital more financial
resources up until when I'm not the one
to say that okay so I didn't
misrepresent your view at all you just
not expressed it okay thank you though I
appreciate it I don't want it I don't
want go around in a circle free sheet
taking the time brother
thank you David now like that
conversation we've entered into a
different topic with Alexis and ended up
talking a bit about rape culture also
you may recall that in that video and if
you want to see it a link is in the
description or playing in this box a
transgender individual opted to the
Third's and there's a dumpster fire and
assault a hobo hobos Tupperware a
container you know what go watch it I
don't want to spoil Alexis Alexis Steven
nice to meet you nice to meet you now I
know that you came up morning to have a
conversation I don't know how familiar
you are at always kind of this segment
that we do change my mind but let me
just explain it to you quickly so we
kind of understand where we're coming
from the idea behind this is to have the
opportunity to rationalize our positions
on controversial topics without it being
edited like you see on cable news
scoring points it's completely unedited
and as it relates to today we've just
talked about male privilege but right
now we've also seen a lot of signs
regarding rape culture here in the
United States not a real thing rape
culture is a myth if you disagree with
me you're more than welcome to tell me
where I'm wrong am i okay yeah I do
disagree with you okay I I for a lot of
reasons rape culture is it's something
that's been going on for not just
decades but for hundreds of years and it
spans cultures and countries all across
the world and and it does lie very much
within male privilege and rape culture
is is compounded by lots of variables so
whether that's in the workplace male or
female
actively engaging with women or men in
inappropriate ways or perhaps you're
walking down the street and a woman is
wearing a short skirt so someone feels
that's that's acceptable to touch her
ass I'm sorry I don't know if I mean you
do that you should do that yes but it's
this capacity we're even law enforcement
when a women a woman who is told if
you're assaulted please go to the
authorities they will handle it and then
someone in a privilege of power let's
say a cop or an attorney or whatever
they ask the question well what were you
wearing that night that permeates we'll
have a conversation afterward to respect
women period so you should respect women
I am the woman so [ __ ] you if you don't
think so I don't really have time for
this I and I don't have time my on stage
you're going to let me speak because
here's my truth I've been breaking more
times
I've known women that have been raped
multiple times gruesomely and how dare
you sit up here and try to say that
women aren't worth respect
Hokkien same woman it's just like are
you [ __ ] kidding me people don't even
respect me period and I'm me I'm already
black so it's just like yeah that
already goes against me anyways but
still [ __ ] my piece of living garbage
ass dumpster fire trash gum on the
bottom of my shoe oh my god I wish I had
a tissue for the flood I would [ __ ]
hurt oh when I suggest that your
behavior not because you're black or a
woman
I'm sorry I'm sorry can I stop here this
guy stopped here twice stop here please
she has just made a statement about
being assaulted which is very vulnerable
and it's very scary to do she just come
here
gentleman just called me a [ __ ] piece
of [ __ ] so I'm saying that's she sorry
my mistake so when did she go from male
privilege to female privilege because
she just said she only became a female
recently
that's not the conversation we're having
it is now that's not the key examine the
right to come in and interject so I
would like to discuss that you said this
video is for the purpose of having a
discussion and it yeah and it wasn't
okay the approach that she made but it
also wasn't okay to antagonize and to
and to just if we're gonna have a
conversation let's go back to what we
originally know I think it's important
because I think that's an example of
female or trans privilege right there
are we talking about white privilege or
of a trans pivot because is it are we
talking about what was that yeah so we
talk about rape culture and what we were
also talking about privilege so so I'm
gonna finish what I was saying earlier
well I would have liked to finish as
well but since we were interrupted I
don't think that wasn't my part nobody
does step in when I was trans back to us
having this conversation on your video I
brought us back cuz you weren't helping
the situation so I brought us back what
I'm helping the situation is about being
truthful these matters I'm going to
finish saying my plan your truth
let's hope it's that truth and not what
that lady was saying thank you I
appreciate that
yeah so within I believe and you're
entitled to that belief sure that woman
very upset made very valid points made
zero valid points one of them being that
if you go to the authorities and they
ask you what you were wearing
whether you're as covered up as I am or
if I was wearing something with my
cleavage hanging out to here
unfortunately people within law
enforcement will say or insinuate that
you had what's coming to you because of
what you were wearing that is one of the
compounds that come with it of rape
culture any statistical bearing to
substantiate that claim can you
elaborate more well you just indicted
our entire police force so do you have
any statistics that would show that rape
is dismissed and cops say if you wore a
short skirt you deserve it because the
statistics that I've looked at rapists
are actually convicted at the same rate
as all other violent criminals even more
and that's great that there's a
conviction rate for that and I'm sorry I
don't have the stats on me right now and
what I've read of legitimate research
and what I know of and it's not about
that it comes down to that should never
be insinuated within any context of a
women saying that she was assaulted or
raped
it should not be invited in for you to
insinuate that what one was wearing had
anything to do with me I would never do
that I don't know the police do that
it's pretty well documented by women
where many people in this country I'm
sorry I can't come up with that right
now for you off the top of my head I
think that matters it does matter and
Adar's to have those resources because
statistically it's not reflected and
what statistics tell you differently
that all statistics that we have
available to us as far as reported rapes
how often rape occurs trials for rape
and convictions FBI and DOJ okay this
and yet and rain yeah and I'm sure that
if you rain is actually uh I know what
rain is okay I know they all reflect
that okay was that mansplaining no just
you sounding like a bit of an ass okay
no offense yeah contrary to our friend
there pretty much I'm not saying that
how they came up and screamed at you was
acceptable because that's not gonna
create a cohesive conversation at all
just excuse the behavior I do not you
just excuse the behavior and that's not
if you're gonna let me finish my
sentence I'm sorry you just I'm sorry
but you just don't gonna paragraph and
then I responded so I'll let you
continue okay but I would like to speak
at some point oh thank you for letting
me speak and I will happily let you
speak in a moment but in regards to the
incident since we want to continue
bringing it up when a woman says that
woman or male however you see her I see
her as a woman when they have said I was
raped four times that is excruciating
for any person and to publicly say that
no woman should have to scream in the
streets that she was raped and that
person get out the screen no they didn't
but they felt that the need to and I was
extremely painful for that person that
was very hard for that person and I
respect that how difficult that was that
for that person okay
that and I wanted to give that person a
hug and they wanted to walk off and
that's okay yeah it's okay you know what
usually happens that's an example of
female privilege there that's a man we
treat them very differently and I'm sure
you're aware of this oh yeah there's
accountability between men
oh absolutely that isn't the same case
with women men don't get in men's faces
and behave that way because there's yeah
okay so let me ask you this to find
woman a woman just gonna I think we're
missing each other here and I don't want
us to that you don't have miss
connections so that sort of spurred this
what is a woman when we're talking about
men's privilege rape culture to find
woman for me so I don't get it wrong
well a woman is any person who defines
herself as if you're looking at
biologically speaking a woman is someone
who has female parts her anatomy is that
of a vagina and having just female parts
and then for me I know I'm a cisgender
female I know this about myself but it's
not about it doesn't matter what I
define myself as it's I ask others what
they define themselves well it doesn't
just biologically female parts obviously
our friend there wouldn't have that so
would that be okay so but that's your
definition of it that's one definition
of it what's your definition of it so
that way I'm not stepping over any
bounds if you were definitely any person
who uses the pronouns he I mean I'm
sorry she and who identifies as such
okay I respect what they identify
themselves out I do not ask them what
their parts are I do not know if there's
a conversation about who's gonna be able
to bear children I will be able to
because of what's why ultimately I nurse
right because we'll be discussing
statistical realities data that would
separate men and women and so I think
it's important that we agree on what
would be defined as a woman versus a man
so you're defining it that way I would
tell you the data then the statistics
that I presented maybe you find to be
completely invalid because it they
always include biological women so okay
I would like to contain the idea of rape
culture I'd like to stay with the United
States that's okay because I would agree
with you that there is there are rape
cultures
elsewhere across the globe and I think
it's a real problem in the United States
though the idea of rape culture and
perhaps you could define it for me but
it's defined in academia on campus is a
culture society where rape is prevalent
and or permissible now it sounds to me
like you were insinuating that's the
case because women aren't believed by
the cops if they go forward with rape is
that sort of your presupposition here as
to why the United States is a rape
culture yes
partially so but I said before there's a
lot of other compounds that come with it
or if there's a law enforcement that
doesn't help protect women yes that's
absolutely going to permeate rape and it
being a culture but do you think that's
the case here I think that's a large
significant reason why rape culture
exists why women are very afraid to go
to the police
because it's a traumatizing it just
traumatising to tell your friend that
you were raped it's traumatizing to go
to law enforcement because they're gonna
ask you to tell you their story and then
you're gonna be asked to say it again
and again and when there's a single
doubt because of a piece of clothing or
the time at which you were out whatever
the case may be and this is not just for
women this is for for men too because
you know men are assaulted and raped as
well and it's even harder more than
women yeah I don't know the numbers on
that so yeah the prison population oh
yeah within prison most definite and
that matters because men over time what
male priviledge are convicted and
sentenced much more harshly for the
exact same crime as women so more men
are incarcerated and overall men are
raped more because of the incarceration
rate so that would be a female privilege
oh yeah if a woman rapes and assaults
someone they should be incarcerated in
the same manner which a man is yeah now
still you're gonna hear more female
cases and not necessarily you're gonna
hear more female cases coming out and
it's it's disappointing and very sad for
men especially in this country who have
been raped because there's a there's a
masculinity component that comes with
that there's a lot of reasons why men
don't come out but rape culture exists
within that too because a man who says
another man was raped that they may be
told while you're gay or you're this or
you're that and unfortunately yeah that
permit that permeates rape culture when
another man confides another man and
says
you're you're a Nephthys or you're sure
whatever a couple of things I think we
need to look at a couple of components
that you've that you've claimed that I
disagree with the idea that rape is
prevalent in the United States yeah I
would say no okay so how I guess what
define prevalent for me because for us
to live in a rape culture would have to
mean that rape is very common and we are
permissible of it now I know you think
the cops and the legal system are we can
get to that but before that define what
we considered prevalent for us to live
in a rape culture as a very well
developed nation considering all that we
have access to in terms of technology
and an education and everything looking
at the me to movement the percentage and
this just the percentage of women who
came out after it after so many women
came out in solidarity it was no one
could believe oh my goodness that many
women in this country have been raped or
assaulted in the country was in
Hollywood okay and you're saying that
Hollywood doesn't necessarily reflect
yes exactly what I'm saying
why so because the rape rate is far
higher in Kali within the United States
the rape rate in the United States the
incidence of rape is very low in
Hollywood is pretty high so within Texas
Dallas Houston and San Antonio being the
three largest cities for human
trafficking yeah we are you know rape is
rape and assault are chronic those are
three major cities and between the three
cities women children and men are carted
off like cattle to be what we know right
do assaulted and everything too much
like sex trafficking yeah yeah I agree
that's a big proponent wall in Texas not
Hollywood
yeah no it's still we're talking about
Texas Texas still would have a far lower
incident of incidents of rape than
Hollywood and I do think do you have the
stats on Texas specifically maybe it is
higher than national I'm sorry I was not
prepared to come here today as you are
well I guess how often do you think rape
occurs well pretty frequently
considering some not some many of the
women in my household within my circles
within as someone who has volunteered
with planned parent
as someone who has invited those
conversations amongst other women and
men in her life it is far more common
than ever expected to be my wife
volunteers at crisis pregnancy centers
that are write off as at Planned
Parenthood sort of the opposite but yeah
she understands that as well she's
working some well I think the rates the
statistics the data do matter not the
anecdotal so first to be a rape culture
how common would rape have to be and
then if you don't have an answer we can
sort of move on to the idea that it's
dismissed I I think it's very hard to
say how common it is when people still
we don't even what's accounted for today
in the data that's that's out there
today is not truly reflective of how
common it is people are scared people
are scared especially if you are a black
woman in this country you're it's very
scary because you're more likely to have
been assaulted you're more likely to
experience police brutality and that's
just a black woman but women in this
country men in this country are very
scared to talk about this now to clarify
this section did get a bit redundant it
droned on and we were discussing with
culture which wasn't really the topic of
the day so I'm going to speed through a
bit here but the entire conversation is
available unedited at lot of credit
accomplished mug club trust me I'm
missing anything but I wanted to provide
full disclosure here we go
so for example we can go to like
Kavanagh do we believe every woman who
makes an accusation I think and I use
that because you know since then we
found out that all of them have been
verifiably false and that was a man
whose reputation was smeared in the
public eye so there's a danger there as
well I'm Julie I fully supported her
going up on that stand
even though there's no evidence than
made for canted but it's not true no I
don't support Kavanagh for a lot of
reasons but when I talking a lot of
reasons we're talking accused of the
heinous crime of rape which we now know
to be false
I still want support Cavanaugh and
that's there's nothing to do about
supporting Cavanaugh can you defend a
man's innocence against false
allegations of rape I don't think any
man should go to prison or anything like
that if they didn't commit the crime
right what should a man's reputation be
tarnished if he didn't commit the crime
at all I believe Christine
soon as a woman's reputation is not
tarnished then I will try not to tarnish
a man's eye reputation I'll put them to
the same bar is it immoral for someone
who knowingly made-up fabricated a rape
story is it immoral for that person to
do so publicly in ruin a man's life
because that's what happened three times
if it happened and that's her story I
believe her story okay first off there
is no story and the two people which I'm
not Ramirez and sweating it kimete up
stories for candidates it's not true and
Christine Blasi Ford only provided
evidence of corroboration that was
immediately discounted by the people who
were questioned regard the collaboration
so my question is why do you believe her
when there is no evidence and there is
evidence to the contrary I believe her
because I I can't imagine what
undeniable pressure she was under and
it's not an excuse for anyone to make up
a story but I do believe that she her
family who started her the people she
loved were threatened and it takes it's
an unbelievable amount of bravery for
what she did it takes an unbelievable
amount of bravery to lie about being
raped for her to go to the stand in
front of many privileged males who
already discounted her story and to
still go up there I I applaud her for
that you so if someone is knowingly
lying about rape you applaud them for it
it is okay what about Julie sweat Nick
and Ramirez they said it was a lie
were they rape it's not the first time
rape victims have recounted because of
unfortunately tremendous amount of
pressure so I can't say that in those
two instances but it's not it's not
undocumenteds documents okay women
tribal sadistic rape is really really
bad as a matter of fact I would advocate
for harsher sentences and we currently
have for rape and certainly compared to
my home country of Canada where a lot of
them get off scot we're not scot-free
but when they often get off with less
than a 20 year sentence I think that
they should practically be buried
beneath the railroad tracks rape
absolutely terrible heinous crime
completely impermissible I'm so glad
that we prosecute these people and put
them behind bars
that being said can you say falsely
accusing someone of rape
yeah oh yeah it's bad okay
good bad room so we were both agree that
what happened with someone like a cabin
are people who are accused of rape with
no evidence is a horrible thing we need
to put a stop to that as well because
that also diminishes real rape that
happened yeah that makes women more
afraid to come forward yes unfortunately
it does I think what you're speaking to
were very publicized it very publicized
occasions and they're the lines between
truth and reality very blurred and
they're not no they're not no they're
not we're gonna disagree they're not and
by the way every high-profile case that
has destroyed men's lives for example
people across those women were believed
do you think that was a good thing that
that woman was believed people across
him woman claims she was raped this was
a big thing and I considered not only a
hate crime not only a sex crime but a
hate crime
UVA Rolling Stone article lives are
destroyed because the women I mean we're
believes that a good thing or a bad
thing
mattress girl Columbia I'm sure you know
mattress girl the guy didn't even go to
his own graduation we now know that was
completely false good thing or bad thing
I would love to give you 400 other
examples that are I don't need to though
is good or bad that women came forward
no evidence I want to wait the details
to say yes or no and I won't give you
yes or no okay let's assume I'm not
lying are you familiar with mattress
girl UVA or Duke lacrosse because these
are the highest profile death cases
before to me to Harvey Weinstein right
and they all were proven false so that
was because women were believed just
like in Cavanaugh scenario without any
evidence and this is by the way the
reason for this is under the guise of a
rape culture and so under the guise that
men should feel guilty and we should
believe all accusers several people's
lives were destroyed with completely
fabricated accusations of rape those
instances UVA Duke Lacrosse mattress
girl of Columbia threat Kavanagh
good thing or bad thing that women were
believed when it turned out they
fabricated it with the exception of
Cavanaugh I'm sorry I'm still not going
to agree with you on that one okay okay
for those other cases I can only say
that I am sorry for anyone's lives who
were destroyed who were innocent and for
all the women who felt to recant perhaps
because of pressure under pressure by
university systems by law enforcement I
give my heart three can't let's not try
to soften it if I can say rape bad rape
accusations that but there's only one of
us here advocating believing claims
without evidence and that's yourself I
believe in evidence I believe in various
forms of evidence okay and according to
what you've said here in this is if
we're going to agree you think that a
claim is valid evidence I think a claim
is something that should be heavily
considered with hopefully evidence but
it is but a claim with no evidence
should be I think we should still try to
fight I think we should still try to
make a case okay but if there is no
evidence there's a claim so you still
continue what I'll still continue
fighting and I'll still if a woman comes
forward with a claim of rape with no
evidence whatsoever
what do you do once you're the legal
system - I'm sorry I don't I can't say I
have a solution for that put me on the
spot because I know that's the goal here
no no it's nothing gold I'm not
understanding where you're coming from
you think I can't I have to have an
absolute opinion in that I can't have
perhaps an in-between opinion you think
I have to because I say I believe in
rape culture that I want to convict all
men and say that any man who looks at a
woman sideways
that I need them convicted you want me
to have an absolute opinion on things
that are very great areas and I won't I
don't think it's a gray area if I can
say rape is bad I believe it should be
just inferred say a rape accusation of
false rape accusation with no evidence
is bad
I think that's bad but I'm not going to
negate a claim either I'm not going to
throw out a claim I won't do it so what
do you do with the claim sorry there's
no evidence and there's evidence no this
matters because of a total red culture
right now we handle rape as we do other
crimes there requires a preponderance of
evidence and rape is a very infrequent
crime in comparison to other crimes with
a similar conviction rate by the way men
are raped more so I have a problem with
rape but if you were insinuating that
there is a rape culture that rape is
more prevalent than it statistically is
and that all claims should be believed I
am asking you what do we do if there is
a claim with no evidence and in
Cavanaugh's case or Columbia mattress
girls case or UVA Lacrosse evidence to
the contrary I think you should find
evidence that corroborates stories
because it's not uncommon for if one
person to experience that others who
have experienced that and to look at
what what are the university's stances
on someone who is raped because there
are some campuses that will highly
discourage you going to the police
how well-documented are there cases of
rape or this or that how well documented
or lack of documentation or what slipped
under the rug because of reputation
purposes
so it starts from a very it starts to
looking at university systems or our
state laws and looking at it from the
very smallest minut side of things to
the larger grand scheme of things I
don't understand with him so if we
collect a hundred pieces of anecdotal
evidence where one woman and a hundred
others say that this man or woman did
this to me it's anecdotal evidence yes
let me explain to you why that should be
discounted and why testimony is the
least reliable form of evidence do you
realize hundred people yeah let me tell
you why do you realize that what you
just did is you encourage a system of
those in power so in other words right
now I could accuse you of a crime and I
can much more easily get a hundred
people to corroborate my story without
any evidence just because I have an
audience does that make it any more
valid I could say that you raped me here
there's no proof it makes it valid now
once again I'm not discounting that yes
evidence is important but it weighs into
if you if a hundred people said I raped
you then right my golly I could do that
very easily something happened to where
the lines between you and I got really
blurred and that needs to be looked into
that needs to be examined if that's the
case what happened between you and I and
yeah for damn sure please someone you
know take us to a courtroom and I want
you know if they all see the same thing
then fine but that needs to be examined
that needs to be examined what happened
okay so your standard is just as long as
people make the claim then we need to
treat it as valid as any other evidence
I should weigh heavily into that I think
it's a very dangerous proposal I believe
in a innocent until proven guilty we
have a current legal system that I think
is a much better standard bearer than X
amount of people said someone did
something that's what led to witch
burning and that's what led to you know
women being predatory societies where
you require a certain amount of
witnesses it's going to lend itself to
men being able to gather well until
proven guilty is is a good system by
which we lead by and I understand that
if I lived in another country where a
guilty until proven innocent
yes we'd be rotting in a jail but I I
know I know of a story just recently and
I'm sorry I can't come up with I can't
say the name come on that's
inappropriate sweetheart
you feel better
oh are you offended by what I said no I
just don't think it's necessary
aren't you just feeding into it you do
realize that's a violent crime correct
you're fine ah-so because there's no
damage done fine okay doesn't bother you
what if that were a man because that's a
woman wouldn't bother you at this moment
okay I don't I think you might need to
check your own privilege and bias if you
think that behavior is acceptable if you
think someone whipping something at
somebody because they disagree with them
is okay because I'm no I'm fine
there was a hundred Trump supporters
here and I didn't say a word to them I
smiled at them wave there couldn't be
less relevant we've had someone who's
come up a committed verbal assault which
is known as battery and then actual
assault and if I went up and kicks it
running through someone yeah probably
wouldn't be okay
but that's not okay no it's not okay but
you seem more offended at me calling a
the man sweetheart no I just think
goading a person isn't necessary I'm not
going they're already down the street
because that man is a coward so I know
you'd think they're brave I think
throwing something and running away not
very brave